during Europe's Middle Ages the
knowledge and advancements in Healing
Arts that had been developed during the
Roman Empire were largely lost or
forgotten Medical Care was limited with
few trained doctors or hospitals
available to the general population
instead traveling Physicians offered
limited Medical Treatments often with
little knowledge or understanding of the
human body in contrast Medical Science
flourished in the Islamic Golden Age
Scholars and Physicians made significant
advances in areas such as Anatomy
surgery pharmacology and medical ethics
these developments were based on earlier
Greek Roman and Indian medical knowledge
which was translated and further
developed by Islamic scholars the movie
opens with a glimpse into the harsh
realities of life in the 11th century
England where we meet the resilient
protagonist Rob Cole as the eldest child
and his family Rob is burdened with the
responsibility of being the sole
Breadwinner he works in the perilous
Minds trying his best to provide for his
mother and two younger siblings one day
a traveling position known as Barber
arrives in Rob's town with his
captivating charm and enigmatic Persona
Barber claims to possess the power to
cure a variety of illnesses that night
Rob's mother suffers from excruciating
pain due to a mysterious disease when he
puts his hand over her chest he feels
something scary and quickly backs away
fearing that his mother is going to die
soon he goes to fetch the only medical
practitioner in town Barber the latter
agrees to help but when they arrive home
a lot of people have already gathered
since medical science is considered
witchcraft the people forbid Barbara
from treating the woman unfortunately
this turns out to be a bad decision as
the woman slowly succumbs to a disease
much to the dismay of her children the
following morning the two younger
children are taken away by the town's
people along with the household utensils
now Rob is left on his own with no one
to care for him so he turns to the only
person who has shown him any kindness
Barber the wandering physician although
hesitant at first Barbara feels pity for
the boy and eventually decides to take
him under his Wang as his Apprentice as
the years passed by Rob and barber
Traverse different lands Healing The
Sick and injured together along the way
Rob grows from a vulnerable child to a
confident and capable young man despite
his Newfound skills and knowledge
however he remains curious about the
human body and longs to explore its
inner workings oh he is also desperate
to learn about appendicitis the illness
that took his mother's life one day Rob
tells Barbara that he wants to see What
Lies Beneath the skin of a human body
however since operations and surgeries
are considered punishable by law Barbara
warns him to never speak of such things
again months later Barber's failing
eyesight due to cataracts begins to
hinder his work as a physician one day a
farmer arrives at their wagon seeking a
tooth extraction as Rob assists in the
procedure by holding the patient still
he feels a familiar sensation of
impending death this is the same
sensation he noticed the night his
mother passed away lo and behold the
patient also passes away on the table
proving his hunch correct after a while
a distraught Rob confides in Barbara
about what he experienced he says that
he can sense if a person is going to die
however Barbara dismisses his concerns
as mere Superstition unwilling to
believe that Rob possesses any special
gift or intuition that night a mob of
angry townspeople gather outside their
wagon accusing them of Witchcraft and
blaming them for the farmer's death they
then beat up the two and throw them out
of their City hey you stop helping yeah
stop stop helping us out despite his
vision problems Barbara continues to
teach Rob the basics of medical
treatment and entrusts him with the care
of their patients as his condition
worsens he is forced to rely more and
more on Rob's skills and expertise one
day a patient suggests that Rob take his
master to a Jewish healer as they are
known to have the ability to cure
blindness Rob is skeptical since
blindness is considered almost
impossible to cure in these times but
nonetheless he decides to give it a try
as he is desperate to help his master
the following morning Rob and Barbara
arrive at the Jewish doctor's residence
and begin in the treatment the procedure
takes days and nights but at the end
Barber miraculously gains his eyesight
back Rob is stunned that medical science
has come this far so he curiously asked
the doctor where he got all of his
information from in response the latter
reveals that he was taught by the
greatest physician of all time IBN Cena
of Isfahan amazed Rob expresses his
desire to travel there but the doctor
reveals that he will be killed before he
can reach it he further explains that in
the land of the Muslims they do tolerate
the Jews but not Christians this is a
heavy blow to Rob's aspirations but he
is still determined to make it to
Isfahan and learn under the tutelage of
Cena his dream is to become a Hakeem the
greatest of all the healers Barbara
tries his best to talk Rob out of it but
the boy seems to have made up his mind
he is tired of the incompetence of the
medical treatment they have been
performing until this day so in order to
broaden his knowledge Rob bids goodbye
to his master and starts the new journey
of his life after traveling for many
months Rob arrives in Egypt before
leaving for Isfahan though he decides to
disguise himself as a Jew to avoid any
potential danger he undergoes
circumcision oh man and adopts the name
Jesse Ben Benjamin to blend in with the
Jewish Community he also watches every
episode of Curb Your Enthusiasm for
Preparation during his journey Rob joins
a group of Muslim Travelers and meets a
woman named Rebecca as they travel
together they come across a village that
has been recently attacked by the
seljukes a group of nomadic tribes who
believe they are chosen by Allah to
punish Sinners the only Survivor of this
attack is a little girl whom Rebecca
decides to take with her Rob using his
medical expertise helps take care of the
girl impressing everyone around him in
the next scene the group is caught in a
terrible Sandstorm in the desert many
are killed on the Spot while the others
get lost in the chaos at the end of the
day only Rob and one other person remain
however when the other person catches
Rob praying to Jesus at night he attacks
and kills him leaving Rob to continue on
his own and after a few more days of
excruciating walking he finally makes it
to Isfahan Rob rushes to enroll in the
medical school hoping that he can
finally meet the legendary IBN Cena but
to his Misfortune he is not only
rejected but also beaten by the guards
and left on the street later Ani is
found by a man who takes him inside a
room and arranges for him to receive
personal treatment from none other than
IBN Cena Rob cannot believe that he has
finally met the best physician in the
world and to top it off he is also
accepted into the medical school making
him scream enjoy as the days pass Rob
gets information about various diseases
which were considered incurable in his
country of England but here they are
mere illnesses which can be treated with
simple remedies one day Rob learns that
Rebecca is still alive so he excitedly
goes to meet her however his expression
quickly changes when she reveals that
she is going to marry a wealthy
businessman that night after treating a
sick woman Rob has a heartfelt
conversation with even Cena he talks
about about his childhood explaining
that his mother died of appendicitis and
that no one was there to save her he
also reveals that he can sense if a
person is going to die Rob wants to
learn everything he can about medical
science but he is disappointed that even
this Advanced Hospital doesn't have the
means to cure appendicitis in response
ibencina says that surgeries are
considered sinful in this part of the
world too but maybe in the next Thousand
Years things will change and it will
though I'm not sure if it's for the
better the next day ibencina brings Rob
with him when he is summoned to the
Palace by the emperor Shah it is
revealed that the Lord of celjuks had
sent his son to propose a peace treaty
but the Shah beheaded him and sent his
severed head back as a refusal in
retaliation the cells you send a man
infected with the black death disease to
isfahana he walks around the city making
sure that his disease can spread far and
wide when he has finally discovered
chaos spreads throughout the city like
wildfire even Cena and Rob have a
discussion with the Shah where they urge
him to evacuate the city to say David's
citizens from the deadly plague that is
spreading rapidly however the shot
disregards their advice and takes no
action instead he asks ibencina to
accompany him in his Hunting Expedition
through the forest Black Death smack
death it's Quail season baby the latter
swiftly refuses and chooses to stay with
his students and confront the outbreak
in no time infected individuals start
pouring in and the hospital becomes
crowded with patients as the situation
worships the soldiers closed the gates
of the city allowing only Nobles to
leave Rebecca's husband is one of them
and he leaves her to die alone
fortunately Rob finds her in the nick of
time and brings her to the hospital he
takes care of her day and night and also
reads her stories meanwhile IBN Cena is
determined to find a cure for the
disease and analyzes the situation he
concludes that the fleas found on mice
are the vectors for spreading the
disease from corpses to the living as a
result he orders the immediate
termination of all mice slowly the
patients begin to recover and the city
reverts to its normal State Rebecca also
becomes healthy and one day she ends up
having coitus with Rob and all it took
was a little mouse genocide in the next
scene all the wealthy people returned to
the city including Rebecca's husband
hence she reluctantly has to go back
with him despite her Newfound love for
Rob meanwhile the Shah arranges a
celebration to honor IBN Cena and his
students for their Brave efforts during
the epidemic after the hospital resumes
its services ibencina assigns Rob to
take care of the new patients one of
whom is suffering from acute
appendicitis the patient is a
zoroastrian who asks Rob to leave his
body for the vultures after his death as
they believe this cleanses their souls
Rob assures him that everything will be
fine but even after his best efforts the
man eventually passes away initially Rob
is distraught but then he remembers that
zoroastrians don't mind if their bodies
are dissected so he takes the corpse to
a secluded place and performs an autopsy
on it he meticulously studies the human
anatomy And also locates the vermiform
appendix Rob even records his research
findings in papers which he keeps safe
during the course of the next few days
the Royal malaws of the city begin a
revolt against the Shah the reason is
that they don't want other communities
residing in their Muslim land in this
instance they join forces with the
celjukes to achieve a common goal of
banishing the Shah and the Jews I'm
sorry
it's not funny the ultimate aim is for
the malaze to rule over eastfahan with
the seljuks using it as a stepping stone
to conquer all of Persia meanwhile
Rebecca discovers that she is pregnant
with Rob's child and goes out to look
for him in the city to her dismay she
sees him being taken away by the malas
who have accused him of necromancy due
to his research on human anatomy to make
matters worse her husband finds out
about her adultery and hence sentences
her to death by stoning the following
day Rob is brought to court where the
malaws accuse him of being a necromancer
and portray IBN Cena as his accomplice
they also present the dissected body as
evidence against them as a result the
court sentences them both to death the
common people are enraged that a Jewish
man has come to their city and committed
a sin so they hurl angry comments at him
this makes Rob very upset soda save
himself and also the Jewish Community he
confesses that he is actually a
Christian unfortunately No One Believes
him yeah and look at his dick he's a Jew
and his sentence is not reversed inside
the confinement cell Rob pleads for his
master's forgiveness ibencina tells him
that he considers him his greatest
student who has contributed greatly to
the field of Medical Science but his
recklessness will now cost their lives
during their final hours inside the
prison Rob shares his knowledge with
ibencina describing the internal organs
and his life experiences with them just
when it appears as if all hope is lost
the Shah orders them to be freed it
turns out he is also suffering from
appendicitis that's lucky and is slowly
succumbing to the sickness he knows that
even Cena and his student have the Cure
so he wants to try it out even if it
means dissecting his body Rob promptly
agrees to help him but only if Rebecca
is freed the Shah having no other choice
orders his soldiers to fight the malas
and bring her back which they do in the
nick of time after all the preparations
are done Rob starts the surgery on Shaw
assisted by ibencina and some other
students it is a nerve-wracking moment
for him as something like this has never
been carried out anywhere in the world
but using his knowledge from the
previous dissection he successfully
removes the affected appendix the Shah
is now out of danger and to repay the
favor he promises to help Rob secure the
safety of his people he orders his
soldiers to escort the Jewish Community
out of the city and provide them with
all the necessary resources for their
Journey outside the war between Isfahan
and the celiuks has erupted with the
malaza attacking the city and burning
the hospital Rob and others gather
people around the east gate to flee the
city but even Cena is nowhere to be
found worried Rob goes back to the
hospital and discovers him there staring
into the abyss with tears in his eyes
the greatest physician of all time hands
robbed the medical records book and
addresses him as Hakeem Robert Cole he
then stays in the room to die while Rob
reluctantly escapes through the exit
following this he along with the others
managed to escape through the gate and
leave the city behind at last Rob's
dream has come true he has become a
renowned physician and operates a
hospital in the bustling city of London
where all kinds of ailments can be
treated he is living his dream life with
his wife Rebecca by his side one day the
old Barber learns about his apprentice's
success from a little boy who has
recently been to the hospital the movie
ends as the two chat all the way there
with Barbara boasting that he taught Rob
how to be great
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching